hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hieß so mache ich am anfang
in china dieses hier sieht so aus als
wenn ich euch irgendwie so einen
gedanken aus meinem kopf raus nehmen und
euch dann ihn gegeben will und das ist
er fällt hier aus meinem kanal und ich
spielen sollte das heerlager game bis
der worum es da geht beim hanauer geht
es darum dass wir auf der einen seite
ich glaube ja alle wissen worum es geht
der macht der linken seite die jusos
spex was auch immer das ist dicke kessen
kennst du die bar genie der pause alles
klar
shirin wird auf jeden fall monatliche
öfter gegoogelt nämlich 18 3 millionen
mal elektrischen elektrischen also ein
elektriker denke meine aussprache ist
mal wieder super toll heute weniger als
18 millionen mal nämlich 135000 mal
hinduismus definitiv mehr würde ich
sagen nämlich auch gar nicht so viel
mehr über 201 1000 kobe bryant ist
glaubt alles klar
ich drück einfach auf seite zurückgehen
mainz course weg die hefte start from
what we do luca konzentrier dich mach
jetzt nicht so viel scheiße ich im
schnitt sondern konzentriere mich
einfach auf das game bitte danke die
findet eigentlich die farbe von diesem
pullover habe ich da etwa erster
zwölfter luca shop gehört
wer weiß wer hier ist mir so ein
bisschen zu lang also der geht mir bis
hier vorne aber erst so flauschig ich
will überhaupt keine werbung
doch ich will schon werbung machen
minister
eurovision hat 823.000 monatliche suchen
und personal ist in würde ich sagen
weniger nehmen nicht nur 49.000 chris
barry diemer ich glaube mehr okay ganz
wenig mehr sogar nur der rock definitiv
mehr das geht in die millionen 12
millionen michigan state im würde ich
sagen weniger nämlich nur 14.800 weiß
was es ist aber dass sie trinken stadion
ist oder hinken football rugby-team
candy crash sage auf jeden fall mehr in
neun millionen inter mailand weniger
allerhöchsten millionen haben eine halbe
million sogar nhl es keine ahnung
northwood university hospital denke ich
auch nicht mal hundert mal okay gleich
vier okay das krass fluten in jeddah wir
haben es aber auch heute mit den games
ich bin mir nicht sicher ich glaube es
ist auch c a gleich viel aber ich bin
mir überhaupt ich kann es überhaupt
nicht einschätzen gerade ene mene miste
es rappelt in der kiste ene mene meck
und du musst also lauer wahrscheinlich
mehr natürlich dekade minister hast du
mich hier schon mal gut behandelt
aber eher freundlich wer besser diesem
spiel und spaß ich weiß noch als ich die
ersten partien hochgeladen habe hatte
ich so 12 und jetzt habe ich einfach so
sieben bis zwanzig dentist böses ford
ford auf jeden fall mehr bei denen habe
ich sogar mal ein praktikum gemacht
oh gott ich würde sagen weniger ok krass
aber voll viel weniger als hinduismus
von subway geht auch in die millionen
nicht 61 millionen martin scorsese sie
kenne ich nicht denke ich laura nämlich
301 1000 research in hat auch weniger
als 300 1 1000 nämlich nur 18.000
general motors auf jeden fall mehr auch
in die millionen 75 millionen effekt
haben weniger auch millionen würde ich
sagen genau aber nicht so viel nintendo
wii glaube ich mehr ich bin mir als wenn
schon wieder sieben ashley madison gegen
rod stewart dicker was wollt ihr von mir
weniger hat natürlich mehr news corp 0
singstar ich bin so gut diesem spiel
black swan suspense würde ich sagen
period hat mehr nämlich 60.000 mehr
south africa hat auch mehr als 300 1
1000 nämlich 550.000 break würde ich
sagen hat auch mehr nämlich genau gleich
viel wie findet ihr eigentlich meine
haare also ich verbinde ja in letzter
zeit immer so ein bisschen gaming mit
ein bisschen real life also ich habe auf
meine cam komplett ran gesund deswegen
meine haare sind jetzt relativ lang wie
gehen wir fast bis zur nasenspitze hier
unten ich wollte einfach mal wachsen
lassen und schauen wo es hingeht und ich
sehe halt ein paar kommentare immer
sollen
kommentaren von euch sogar mal zum
friseur egal was ihr penner aber ein
paar schreiben halt auch so aus wie ich
habe keine ahnung ich mach die
derzeitigen die ich hab da auch fast
nichts drin
ich weiß bin ich mit beauty kanal mag
ich das abfackeln dieser contra vom
thema abkommen
bungee jumper denke ich weniger als raid
nämlich 165.000 christopher kolumbus hat
ich würde sagen mehr aber auch nicht
viel mehr nämlich fast 900.000 mehr find
my iphone er definitiv richtig viel bei
jeder pädagoge sein handy verlieren
antidepressiva würde ich sagen weniger
als 1 5 millionen nämlich 135000 apple
watch hatte auch millionen mäßig 33
millionen taiwan weniger hat annähernd 1
millionen live ist jude
es ist ein buch weniger als taiwan würde
ich sagen nämlich 165000 ist nice
carpenter würde ich sagen weniger oder
welse kingsley wahrscheinlich mehr
yorkshire terrier definitiv weniger als
putin dann haben wir als nächstes
biester island hat auch weniger als in
yorkshire terrier freak hat glaube ich
mehr als 200 1 tausende nicht 5
millionen okay das ist nicht jeder das
so krass ist megan fox denkt ich weniger
als fünf millionen nämlich 27
hatten wir letztes auch dieses video
glaube ich sogar schon vor allem judis
muss alter luca heißt der nicht judentum
oder so könig der löwen hat mehr ist ja
eines der krassesten musicals film
whatever paris hat auch denke ich in die
millionen 27 millionen metropole es
würde ich sagen weniger weiß ich ganz
genau was es ist vielleicht eine sendung
oder so björn borg auch weniger nämlich
tanja 100.000 royal family hat glaube
ich mehr aber auch nicht so viel genau
gleich viel okay das ist krass andre
agassi hat auf jeden fall mehr fast
schon millionen ok 135000 alles klar
dicker mich wird ist so krass
interessieren wie oft ich gegoogelt
werden monatlich also ich weiß ja wie
viele ergebnisse kommen wenn ich meinen
namen gebe aber ich weiß halt nicht so
wie wie oft monatlich wisst ihr jet li
würde ich da an hat weniger als agassi
hat auf jeden fall mehr elf kann nicht
einmal richtig gut dann im spiel weil
gerade bin ich echt sehr schlecht das
was sie von dem video meiner damen wenn
es euch gefallen lassen fetten like da
würd mich mega freuen
hier findet hier irgendein video
eingeblendet und die wenn ihr darauf den
smiley klick könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren ich hab mir auf die lippe
gespuckt abonniert mich einfach mal weil
es letztlich neuen abonnenten und wenn
ich auf das video klickt dann kriege ich
dann mehr aufrufe ja schreibt mir was
sie von diesen pulli haltet weil ich
finde den mega geil